hi my name is nicholas cargolias and i'm
a phd candidate at uc berkeley where i
study rice developmental genetics and
physiology while i find my research very
interesting
today and my talk i'd actually hope to
share a bit more about uh broadly about
gene editing
for climate change and agriculture
it's really an honor to be here albeit
virtually back at my alma mater where i
got my bachelor's degree in agricultural
sciences and so thank you for the
privilege of having me today and i'm
very excited to share
our team's research findings in terms of
how gene editing has been applied for
climate change in agriculture and also
share a bit about the synergies between
gene editing and more conventional
breeding and so with that i'd like to
begin with telling you a bit about my
background and so
these folks here are my parents visiting
me here out in the bay area and before
they made it to visit me in san
francisco they immigrated from the small
island nation of cyprus now
this nation is primary economy is driven
primarily by agriculture and tourism and
so my paternal grandparents had
uh farms where they raised citrus crops
and olives like the ones that you see
here
so agriculture has always been a part of
my kind of ancestral narrative and i've
seen firsthand how individuals like my
parents have been impacted by
agricultural innovation
so i just wanted to establish a bit of
context for why
i'm really inspired to do this work
because it represents uh my family's
history and when my parents came over to
this country they actually continue to
work in the food industry so food has
kind of always been in the narrative and
i can see the ways that technology can
be incredibly potent in establishing uh
the livelihoods of folks like my family
and so with that i'll transition to tell
you a bit about what i hope to achieve
today and so
i would like to provide an overview for
how gene editing has been applied in
crops and in livestock to address
climate change
and and doing so i'd i'm going to bring
in a few case studies that really help
emphasize just how potent this
technology can be
um i also hope to draw in the uh
synergism that can exist between
breeding and gene editing and conclude
with some final remarks
so
as you've all probably are well aware of
climate change stands to impact the food
system quite negatively
and the environmental outcomes of
climate change are wide-ranging and
quite severe
climate change might facilitate
increased salinization
enhanced droughts
increase the concentration of co2
temperatures these are
statistics and phenomena that have been
looming for a while and that we have
been aware of
and i just want to emphasize here how
devastating climate change is and will
continue to be in terms of agricultural
systems some of the impacts that we can
anticipate are increased disease
severity as a result of expanding the
host ranges of a lot of pathogens or
disease-causing agents
decreasing the ability of crops and
livestock to manage their resistance
disease among a plethora of other
impacts heightening the disease severity
in crops and livestock
projections
more or less always converge on an
understanding that yields whether vegan
crops or in livestock will be lowered as
a result of the impacts of climate
change and we can also anticipate lower
nutritive quality primarily of our crops
so collectively we know that climate
change will negatively impact our food
systems and
this figure this understanding of how
climate change will impact our food
systems is not necessarily
all-encompassing but meant to highlight
kind of the most poignant impacts that
we can anticipate
so with this bleak understanding of food
systems in the face of climate change i
hope to create a little bit of hope for
us and understanding what can we do
about it specifically in the lens of
gene editing
and so
the work that has uh surfaced to address
climate change and agriculture has
converged into four major traits and
those are disease mitigation enhanced
yields abiotic stress tolerance and
nutritional improvement and all of these
traits our phenotypes stand to be
affected by climate change um and so
it's very hopeful or promising to see
that there has been a large body of work
in embracing the realities of climate
change and being able to address them
quite effectively through the
applications of gene editing
and so
i want to share a bit about what that
work has looked like on a temporal scale
so there's been a really recent surge of
innovations that have been facilitated
by gene editing and you can see here in
both crops and livestock
this
figure is skewed left so there's been a
primarily a large surge of innovations
that have happened recently
especially if you look at the year 2018
for example and this is largely this
recent surge in innovation i believe can
be largely attributed to the uh
innovation of crispr cas9 editing and so
the first eukaryotic cells were edited
in 2013 and regenerated plants were
occurred for the first time in 2015. and
so you can see that crispr cast 9 and
the advent of
ability to use crispr cast 9 in vivo has
really facilitated a recent surge of
innovations which is exciting and
creates a lot of promise for how gene
editing innovation will continue to
merge and continue to be a potent
mechanism to address the emerging and
current uh
impositions of climate change
and so beyond temporal scale uh
understanding that gene editing can be
applied widely uh biologically so you
see here separated in green for crops
and purple for livestock the range of
organisms that have successfully been
gene targeted i mean there is an
expansive set now organisms that have
had this technology successfully applied
to them and you can see that
these organisms range from staple crops
like wheat and maize and rice all the
way to more
locally imported crops like ground
cherries and so this is a really
exciting understanding that this
technology can be expansive for
global staple crops um local populations
and um
among a variety of traits and you can
see the same is true in livestock there
are quite severe bottlenecks in
livestock editing
in terms of regeneration and tissue
culture that are need to be surmounted
in order to expand the range of
organisms
livestock organisms that can be targeted
for improvement with gene editing but
this figure is meant to establish an
understanding that
gene editing can indeed be applied to a
wide variety of organisms and this
enhances the potency that gene editing
technology
stands to offer
and so
what is that potency what has this
technology achieved
you can see here a gallery of figures of
gene edited organisms all for different
traits and so
everything highlighted in orange is a
yield improvement trait in blue is
nutrition quality improvement trait
red and abiotic stress tolerance trade
and in green is a
disease resistance trait and so
i think let's start with the orange
because they're the most visually
striking in my opinion you can see a red
sea bream on the left one that's been
edited at a single locus the mstn gene
which is a locus myostatin gene thought
to be able to increase muscle mass and
based on visual inspection i'd say that
is indeed the case a red sebring that
had been edited accumulated 16
skeletal muscle on average um below that
you can see that same locus being
targeted in cattle and the cow on the
right is a little bit more muscular than
the one on the left
um
alternatively you see that yield
improvements have also been achieved in
crops
in this case tomato promoter editing of
important uh tomato inflorescence and
developmental genes
yielded fruit with increased
locul numbers and fruit size and so i
think that's a very striking image of
how gene editing could be applied to
enhance yield
what's more is in nutrition you can see
the beta carotene accumulation in this
banana that has been facilitated by a
knockout of a single gene
in chickens you can reduce the amount of
fat accumulation on the gi tract
which will be an important mechanism for
lowering the negative food quality
attributes present in livestock
you see on the bottom left in rice a
gene editing approach that enhances
saline resistance um
like i mentioned previously climate
change is anticipated to increase the
salinization and so
you can see uh that plant on the left
that's wild type and on the right are
rice plants that have been edited for a
single gene and they are
growing larger by far on average
and then finally we get to disease
resistance and crops and lifestyle so
the pigs that you see
are ones that have been gene edited
successfully and they are resistant to
um
horstene respiratory virus and so when
challenged with the virus these pigs are
the only ones that survive and their
counterparts their wild type
counterparts actually need to be
euthanized because the severity of the
disease
and finally you see on the right um
field trials of gene edited
rice plants for broad spectrum
resistance in this case they're
challenged with rice blast in the field
and you can see that the rice on the
right looks a lot healthier and it will
yield on average 50 percent more per
hectare based on
having a single gene edit a single locus
i think at this point given the data
shared it's undeniable that gene editing
is an incredibly powerful technique and
technology to facilitate improvements in
crops and livestock alike for uh
addressing climate change and addressing
performance issues beyond the
impositions of climate change um and so
this is an incredibly exciting
technology but it by no means does it
forego
or lessen the importance of conventional
breeding techniques that have existed
before gene editing and will continue to
persist beyond it as you all are well
aware
alternative breeding mechanisms are
incredibly important
before i transition to describing the
synergies between gene editing and
reading i just wanted to highlight one
final example
uh where gene editing had been applied
to ground cherries and using information
garnered from tomato to be able to
increase fruit size
and you can see here increase flower
patterning as well or modify flower
patterning and so
it's exciting to see how gene editing
can be expansive in terms not only of
improving
major global staple crops but also
enhancing the performance of more
locally adapted um
crops like ground cherries so similar to
breeding
gene editing is increasingly gaining the
capacity to be potent uh as disruptive
technology and and local economies and
in local food systems as well as
globally
and with that i'd like to speak a bit
more about how
gene editing and um
conventional breeding coalesce and so
um i'm bringing you here this example of
maze waxy lines that were developed
through gene editing in elite background
in an elite background versus
waxy lines that have been produced by
hybridizing or introgressing that waxy
allele from
into the elite background
and so you can see here that both
approaches were able to achieve high
percentages of amylopectin which was
that desired waxy phenotype what you see
on the right however is that on average
those inbred lines that had been gene
edited
were higher yielding and so we know at
well that linkage drag is a very severe
attribute
associated with breeding and in this
case because amylopectin uh increasing
percentages of amylopectin for a waxy
variety um is such a discrete
locus they were able to simply gene edit
a single locus and achieve in an elite
background in less time
higher yielding waxy maze whereas
hybridizing to achieve that same trait
um took longer and uh yielded less and
so you can see here that the advantages
of gene editing relative to let's say
back crossing in order to achieve a
trait of interest simply in saving time
and in bypassing linkage drag
now on
on the flip side of that uh
gene editing falls short when there
aren't discrete loci
that can easily be targeted and my work
at cornell actually helped me
recognize this reality in which i sought
to improve the aluminum tolerance or
understand through g wasps the aluminum
tolerance and tropical japonica
sub-population of rice which is one of
the most aluminum tolerant
sub-populations and the g-wasp that we
got looked a bit like this where there
was no significant association detected
of any region in the genome and we
thought this to be very curious because
the tropical japonicos were indeed quite
aluminum tolerant and so we uh
conjectured that it was the accumulation
of many small effect alleles that
actually contributed to
the aluminum tolerance that was detected
in tropical japonica and sure enough
when you looked at lines that had been
ad mixed into
tropical japanic alliance with admixture
from other subpopulations those on
average
were lower ranking and lower performing
than pure lines
in aluminum treatment and so this was
quite curious
it seems to us that in tropical japonica
at least there is a loss of additive
heritability and that the aluminum
tolerance is conferred by many small
effect utls in an understanding of kind
of the infinitesimal model of
inheritance for traits and so
this is meant to substantiate the
necessity and importance of breeding
efforts um
as they cannot always
as important traits cannot always be
addressed with editing individual loci
or even multiplexing edits in the case
of aluminum tolerance and subtropical
japonica there would be no target
discernible that could be uh improved
with by gene editing and so this is just
to really
meant to substantiate and drive home the
point that breeding remains essential
and that there is uh
opportunities to coalesce or combine
these approaches to maximize throughput
and so that's this final example here in
which gene editing had been used to
dissect quantitative trait loci uh
detected and amazed g wasp uh uh
targeted to understanding the
architecture the genetic architecture of
day's tan thesis and so they were able
to
define two important loci
and then
select candidate genes within those loci
detected via giwas and maize and you see
here in the figure on the right those
are representing different timing days
10 thesis for example days to seed um
and you can see that the three genes
defined on the right when knocked out um
actually improve the shorten more
significantly those days to anthesis
relative to previously characterized
genes in black and so
the application of crispr class 9
technology to dissect the qtls unravel
novel genes that have not been
previously identified in association
with this trait and underlies the
importance of fusing conventional
breeding with gene editing approaches
and so with an improved understanding of
how gene editing and
conventional breeding contribute to
synergy i would like to put out a call
to coalition for the folks here whether
they be gene editing folks or readers
and with that i'd just like to wrap up
so
in this talk i conveyed the potency of
gene editing and its ability to address
the impacts of climate change on
agriculture
gene editing recently has seen a surge
of innovation
and as a breeding tool can really
facilitate
rapid enhancements and potent
enhancements to traits that will be
affected by climate change
all nonetheless conventional techniques
and breeding remain essential as gene
editing is not panacea but just another
tool in our kit for advancing um
our ability to address agriculture in
the face of climate change and
the impacts of these technological
innovations be they gene editing or
breeding
can only be realized via effective
translation to grower so
i thank you for your time uh and your
attention and for the opportunity to
speak here with you all today with that
i'd like to acknowledge the folks who
made a lot of this work possible
um and i'm happy to take any questions
you might have in our
panel discussion
thank you